The Joe Rogan Experience you know the
stem cell thing uh if he could if Von
Doom there could get on uh on the
eyeball I'd be very appreciative that
would have do they let's tell everybody
what happened to you because this is a
crazy thing
um uh it's a real bummer right you
you're just out of nowhere started
seeing dark spots right no what happened
was well a little background I had
already
um
stage one was going into your local
doctor eye guy because you have metal in
your eye oh wow because that's some of
the fun that happens even when you're
wearing safety glasses all the haters
calm down and wear safety glasses oh it
just bounces around you know you're
working with a carbide bit spinning at
you know 15 000 RPM stuff bounces around
but since then I have I have been using
I found this place in France that makes
these Mo Antique motorcycle war one
aircraft goggles to use for duels
I I don't know that one you don't know
that but but it seals to your eyes and
it's got little vents in it so they
don't fog up so but anyway I got metal
in my eye which is uh for those of you
who haven't done it it's lots of fun
um you hold still you're wide awake and
they come at you with a Dremel drill bit
and they drill it out so and you and the
in the instructions are hold still don't
move right oh my God I mean they put a
numbing drop in but so what do you still
see the drill bit coming and yeah easy
easy you can hand it the stuff you've
been doing through I'm sure you can
handle it yeah that's wild but so so
I've been drilled a couple of times that
sounds wrong
and it if they came up with a photo of
my eye it looked like a golf ball little
dimples when the drill comes in so
anyway that guy is like you know when
they're in there if they're experienced
cats they just happen to look around
right yeah and he goes hey
um
I think you should come back and talk to
our other doctor so and so and have him
do some tests because I saw some stuff
don't know but I think it'd be wise if
you blah blah blah so I go in we do the
test and the guy goes and this is wow
this is a while ago
14 15 years ago here we are again with
that time portal right
um
he goes you have advanced glaucoma then
I go
what the hell is that
he goes it's like creeping death
slowly takes your peripheral and most
adults don't know that they're going
blind until they're 80 and it's moved so
slow
that you don't you don't notice the
change right well mine's Trucking along
and so we start with medication that
lowers in your eye
you basically got a faucet and a drain
and if the drain's plugged up or if the
faucet's on overload it's acting not
like a water balloon but pressure builds
that pressure
is think of your optic nerve
right your brain is the cable TV company
your eye is the expensive flat screen TV
and the cable connecting the two of them
right that pressure building up is like
somebody with a heel of his boot digging
on that cable and sooner or later
all right nothing right so you take
medicine to reduce the pressure so it
doesn't eat away at the optic nerve goes
okay great we got that under control
we're killer
so then um
oh probably eight nine years ago I have
cataract surgery in my right eye
and
um
put the cataract lens in and it's like
oh my gosh
it's a crystal clear and beautiful and
incredible you know stoked on it about a
year passes and I'm at PRI which is the
race real serious race version of Sema
it's in Indianapolis so there's no fuzzy
dice there it's all race car parts and
stuff like that and I'm walking around
and I just I don't know how to describe
it but it actually moved in stages like
a curtain coming down of just Gray
and then you just saw Gray
and it was my retina falling off
retention
so I'm in Indy
and I fly back and get together with the
doctors and they're like you got to put
that [__] up
and
um instead of doing the long version
I'll give you the short version seven
surgeries later
and every time you have the surgery
there's stitches in my eye I'm and
that's fun
that's way more fun than the drilling
and you're laying face down for a week
oh boy can't move
and it just kept falling off they
couldn't they couldn't go up so I went
to another surgeon I also have a buckle
permanently sewn
into my eye they try to change the shape
of the eye to promote the retina staying
up better oh boy so anyway
um
got to new doctor great guy Dr osmali
back home in Cali and he's like I got
this man there's other guys they're
losers we're gonna get it up there and
we're gonna stick it up
that was surgery six
and uh it didn't hold and he was more I
think he was more depressed than I was
and uh so we scheduled seven and he sat
down with me I remember before we went
into uh into the operating room he goes
look
I I don't think I can I'm gonna go try
to save your eye
I'm not going to save your site because
and he he did it this way which I
thought was cool he went and did a
little research to speak in my language
and he goes when you're trying to weld
metal
if both the pieces are kind of rusty and
beat up or whatever that it won't weld
very good right I'm gonna go true you go
so you gotta have clean metal to clean
metal to weld I go yes that's true
he goes well all the attempts
have just taken away the living oh Jesus
[__] out of the
um
retina so I'm gonna cut away the yucky
stuff
and I'm gonna have a new Edge to
they they use a laser they basically the
only thing they know how to do is tack
weld it up that's what they do right so
he goes I'm going to make new clean
edges
I'm going to weld it up
you're going to lose some sight at least
because I'm taking away part of the
retina
but I'm going to save your eye because
if the eye if we can't get something
going on in there
then your body will kill off your eye it
shrinks back it's painful pop it out put
a glass eye in I go yeah let's yeah
let's not
so he did that
and uh he goes I cut away about a third
of the retina and I had a visual like a
vertical rectangle of sight
right not all the way over to here to
here here to here but fast forwarding
Scar Tissue moved over and pretty much
just eliminated they're like we can go
in and I'm like no no no we're not going
to go in and do it anything Jesus
um so this one's basically gone you know
that's that for now and we'll see if
science checks in do you know who
Michael Bisping is
no sir Michael Bisping is one of the
toughest human beings that's ever walked
the face of the Earth this is what I was
and not just because he was UFC
middleweight champion but because
Michael Bisping fought the last 10
fights of his UFC career including
winning the title blind in one eye
and he didn't tell them he hid it oh I
heard about that yeah he hit it he
didn't tell anybody do you know gangster
you have to be to want to be fighting
the best fighters in the world Dan and
not being able to see Anderson Silva and
you can't see out of one eye like his
his one eye is gone man yeah I
understand which is fighting world-class
Fighters that you can see his right eye
is completely missing it's like it's
just foggy yeah he wears like a little
thing that goes over it like a lens so
it looks normal but uh he's a [__]
stud that guy fought 10 fights with one
eye we just think of a fight with two
eyes is [__] terrifying and fighting
against the best guys in the world and
he wins the title knocks out Luke
rockhold with one eye yeah well it took
a lot I I would sit there and practice
like basketball into uh garbage cans
just to try to retain the um
perception that's the real issue right
yeah it's difficult and then also it's
it's frustrating when you're uh so well
anyway the the fun I'll interrupt myself
to continue with the fun so now I'm
where I'm at right and they're like
your other eye is going to need cataract
surgery oh Jesus and I'm like so I did
ask
when the retina fell off
hey did the cataract surgery have
anything to do with that possibly you
know and every doctor and every
specialist and everybody I talked to all
said the same thing
I'm paraphrasing
well
any procedure on your eye may could
might possibly have the possibility of
like one of them's commercials drug you
know so it's like did the operation on
your eye cause the retina fall off
uh anything could maybe anything could
maybe so anyway so now I've got to have
cataract surgery on this one I got a
great guy who's one of the best in the
west coast
et cetera Etc
we do the surgery
and there is a
mistake
in because their account for my
pressures they try to keep the pressures
low because of my glaucoma
well they
went a little too far and my pressures
were down your normal eyes run like your
eyes probably run at like 20 22
you know maybe even a little bit higher
but right around there for pressure
inside we'll call it we'll call it air
pressure you know it's not the right
term but so mine with medication we keep
it down at like 13 and 12. right okay so
um
when after the second cataract surgery
the one on the one working eye they had
dropped the pressure so low
I coughed and it blew out blood vessels
inside my eye
which when you wake up and you look it
looks like it's snowing inside your it
looks like it's snowing and I'm like
what the hell is going on and at the
same time we did a special little
surgery to like drill out the drain tube
because in my eyes the faucets wide open
and the drain tubes plugged that builds
the pressure so the medicine turns the
faucet down and clears away the drain
tube right so we drill out the drain
tube I'm over I'm making this with I'm
sure there's eye guys listening that's
not technically look they're thrilled
the description right they drilled the
damn tube open so all the blood goes
down and plugs that so that ruined that
yay and so they rushed me and they
basically take a needle and insert fluid
into my eye I'm wide awake mind you
just too little you ever been where the
two handles under the table oh yeah yeah
oh my gosh [__] does he have
your head secured or anything no you
just put it in the little foamy Breeze
oh boy so they do that and that was
miscalculated and the pressures went to
like 62 and I I was I was
um what's the word terrified no I I was
throwing up I couldn't stand up I was so
disoriented because I mean it was
screwing with the deal
and so the doc who again great guy I'm
still I'm not slamming him and he
actually met me at his office so like
I don't even know when it was three in
the morning or
and and I'm throwing up in his bushes
out front
oh my God right and he did this
three times
heading the thing hands on the handle
took a blade lifted my eye and let the
let the pressure out let the fluid out
so I'm like taking that right so now we
get the pressures under control right
and so that was uh
two to three years ago and believe me
every day when I wake up and I can see
Mike is this the day this retina falls
off
I'm not going to have a repeat of the
last one oh my God I have clammy hands
I really do I'm the one to living
through it you don't have to worry about
it you're good but still it's for you
yeah it's you know but it's like
anything else when someone has something
they
uh uh when Sutton is always over your
shoulder you can either focus on it
and worry about it or just go to the
shop and build some cool cars you know